all right let's do this one last time
welcome back everyone i'm rocket riley
and spider-man across the spider-verse
part 1 is one of the most eagerly
anticipated movies of 2022 and for good
reason it's the sequel to the 2019
award-winning film spider-man into the
spider-verse so it's pretty much
guaranteed to be one of the best films
over the next year we're gonna go over
everything we know so far about the
movie including rumors news updates cast
details and more the upcoming film by
sony imageworks will reunite us with
miles morales gwen stacy and peter b
parker the film will follow these three
as they journey across the spider-verse
to stop a new threat to each of their
realities and a certain version of
spider-man is already confirmed to be in
the movie miguel o'hara or spider-man
2099 since the huge success of
spider-man no way home we can probably
expect this film to be one of the
highest grossing films of the year but
let's not get ahead of ourselves for now
let's go over everything we know so far
about spider-man across the spider-verse
part 1. so far rumors suggest that we'll
be seeing multiple animation styles when
our main characters enter different
universes potentially including the
marvel cinematic universe which was
recently hinted at by the film's
co-writers if the characters do enter a
universe we've seen before in film we
can expect to see characters such as
tobey maguire's andrew garfield's or tom
holland spider-man other spider-men are
also expected to make an appearance in
the sequel including john mullaney
spider-ham kamiko glen's penny parker
and nicholas cage's spider-man noir the
teaser trailer also hinted the potential
arrival of spider-man india since the
word thwip was written in hindi when
miles shot as webs and the film's
co-screenwriter and executive producer
phil lord has hinted that the japanese
spider-man may appear as well the
japanese spider-man also known as takuya
yamashiro first appeared in the japanese
television series spider-man from the
late 1970s as spider-man's popularity
began to rise in japan the television
show deviated pretty heavily from the
source material of the comics his
presence in the film could allow for the
story to explore some alternative
spider-man stories as this version of
the character's powers actually came
from outer space but it's unclear if any
of these characters will make
appearances for certain originally
scheduled for an april 2022 release date
across the spider-verse part 1 is now
set to hit theaters on october 7 2022
work on the film began in november of
2018 so it's not likely we'll see any
additional delays to the release date at
this point sony pictures released a
teaser trailer for the film on saturday
december 4th which doesn't give too much
away about the film's plot but we do get
confirmation that both miles morales and
gwen stacy will reunite in his universe
and that miles will travel to some new
dimensions where he'll have his first
encounter with spider-man 2099 the
teaser also showed that the film will
retain a lot of the humor and action
which helped make the first movie such a
success as of now there are 5 confirmed
cast members but we can expect this list
to continue to grow as more details are
released shamiq more will return to
voice miles morales as well as haley
steinfeld as gwen stacy and jake johnson
as peter b parker shmeek moore is known
for his leading role of malcolm in rick
was dope hayley steinfeld is known for
her role as kate bishop in the disney
plus series hawkeye and jake johnson is
known for his role as nick miller in the
fox sitcom new girl the other two
confirmed cast members are oscar isaac
who will voice miguel o'hara or
spider-man 2099 and issa rae who will
voice jessica drew or spider-woman oscar
isaac is known for his role as poe
dameron in the star wars sequels and as
mark specter in the upcoming series moon
knight while issa rae is known for her
role in the hbo series insecure while
most of the film's plot details have yet
to be confirmed we do have an official
synopsis miles morales returns for the
next chapter of the oscar-winning
spider-verse saga an epic adventure that
will transport brooklyn's full-time
friendly neighborhood spider-man across
the multiverse to join forces with gwen
stacy and a new team of spider people to
face off with a villain more powerful
than anything they've ever encountered
the two co-writers for the film
christopher miller and phil lord noted
that every dimension looks and feels
radically different from all the others
they all look like they were drawn by a
different artist so we can expect to see
many different art styles used
throughout the movie as well as spider
people that we have yet to see before
the two also teased that the events of
spider-man no way home could have
implications for miles and gwen in the
upcoming sony picture in the recently
released teaser trailer miles and gwen
look older than they did in the first
film so it's likely been a year or two
since they said their goodbyes and into
the spiderverse we also know that miles
will be jumping across universes the
opposite of what happened in the first
film when all the other spider people
came to his universe as for the movie's
main villain i don't think it's likely
to be spider-man 2099 even though he's
seen wrestling with miles in the teaser
trailer it's likely that he's simply
confused about who miles is or that he's
trying to recruit him to fight against
the film's main villain the movie's
villain could be one of many including
the spot green goblin doctor octopus
venom tyler stone craven the hunter or
even another spider-man variant such as
the superior spider-man which i actually
made a video on that'll be linked at the
end of this video part 2 of across the
spider-verse is expected to release
sometime during 2023 and we can probably
expect a fall or winter time frame
spider-man into the spider-verse came
out in december 2018 while across the
spider-verse part 1 comes out in october
2022 so if sony and marvel stick to a
similar release schedule for part 2 of
the franchise it will likely be released
between october and december of 2023
this movie is sure to bring both classic
and strange spider-man stories together
across film television comics and more
and we can expect to see tons of action
comedy and absurdity for a list of the
top 10 most absurd spider-man stories
that might show up in the film check out
this video also don't forget to
subscribe like this video and thanks for
watching rocket rightly
you